[موسيقى]
وقلت اربع خمس مرات لكن قبل السبعين كانت
المسائل
اسهل بكتير وتاخذ مساله ايام او اسبوع
اسبوعين ويتم الافراج عن المعتقد تعذيب
كما حصل معك لاحقا قد يحصل بعض التعذيب او
التهديد يعني لا يتعدى الضرب على الاجرين
يعني سموها بسوريا الفلقه
لكن بعد السبعين طبعا يختلف الامر تماما
يعني فعدد من
استدعاءات والاعتقالات يعني عديد لكن بعد
السبعين اعتقلت مرتين مره في 79 واستمر
الاعتقال تقريبا سنه
خرجنا في الثمانين
والمره الثانيه في اخر 81
استمر 13 سنه فكان المجموع حوالي 14 سنه
اعتقاد تجربتي الشخصيه هي فقط لانتمائي
لحزب سياسي معارض للنظام ويطالب باسقاط
الديكتاتوريه العسكريه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
شخص صديقي اللي هو الجزء الثاني او المكون
الاخر
اعتقل بسبب لنقل
تقرير كتب اصدقائه
بفرنسا وعند عودته الى سوريا من المطار تم
اعتقاله وهو مسيحي وبتهمه الاخوان
المسلمين يعني تقريبا نفس ظروفك نفس
الاعتقال نفس الاعتقال نفس الاعتقال سواء
بالتحقيق او بالحياه اليوميه او بالمضيق
او بالحرمان
وحرمان من الزيارات حرمان رؤيه الاهل كل
هذا يعني
ما يسري عليه يسري عليه يسري على جميع
المعتقلين خاص وانا استاذنته قلت اجري دمج
بين تجربتك وتجربتي
وساستعير هذه المفارقه الحاده بانه يتم
اعتقال شخص مسيحي بتهمه اخوان مسلمين يعني
[موسيقى]